Many of our students responded to this question by saying that the word outlet,
reminded them of the outlet in the wall.
Now this, as you know,
is a connection between electrical appliances at home, and the electric grid.
In much the same way, an outlet in iOS is also a connection,
it's a connection between our code, and something on the story board.
Let's see how this works in code.
So, to manage screen space, I will slide out the utility area, and
then go on to assistant editor, there.
Then I will hold down Ctrl on my keyboard, click on this label,
and then drag to the top of this class and let go.
Here I have a popup that I can fill in.
The type of this connection is an outlet, I will call it recordingInProgress.
The type of this label in iOS is called UILabel.
UI stands for User Interface.
And then I will hit Connect.
Okay, so I have some code here, that X code has written for me.
Let's unpack this line.
So, we created a variable called recordingInProgress,
the type of this variable is UILabel.
Here, we also see something called IBOutlet.
IB stands for interface builder.
And IBOutlet tells developers like us that hey, this variable is not an ordinary
variable, but is linked to the storyboard or the interface builder somehow.
Another thing to notice here is this keyword, weak.
What you should know about this for
now is that this keyword allows us to manage memory for our variable.
And weak as opposed to what?
Strong.
That's right, strong is also a keyword in iOS.
Both weak and strong help us manage memory for our variables.
The keyword means, hey I initialized that variable, so
keep it around till I don't need it anymore.
Weak on the other hand means, someone else created that variable, someone else.
And all I want to do is have a weak reference to that variable.
Now, if you want to learn more about these 2 keywords, weak and strong,
we found a great stack overflow page, that explains these two really well.
The link to that page is in the instructor notes.
So if I return to my code, I can see that we also have a bang or
an exclamation point here at the end.
Is this our way of demonstrating excitement for declaring this variable?
Not quite.
The real answer lies around in idea and swift called Optionals.
Swift allows us to declare a variable, like we have done here.
And it also allows us to not declare any value for
this variable in our code, or have its value be, Optional.
There is a document in the instructor notes that explains optionals and
these exclamation points in detail.
I encourage you to bookmark it for now, and read it later.
Okay, now that I have an outlet to this label in our code.
I can go back to this function, remember, this is the action that gets called
when we press the microphone button, and change the visibility of our label.
So I can say, recordingInProgress, and there is an auto complete.
I can say, it is no longer hidden, there.
So what I'm saying here, is that when this microphone button gets pressed,
this record audio function gets called.
And at that point I do not want this label to be hidden anymore.
All right, let me run this code and see what happens.
All right, so I don't see the label when the app first launches which is good.
And when I press the microphone button, the label starts to show.
That's great.
So, I'm going to go back to my code, slide out my debug area, and
then remove this one TODO, because we've already done it now.
Done.